please search for fragments of the
missile that hit this residential
neighborhood in Kiev they want to know
exactly what it was the Russians fired a
whole range of weapons across the
country shattering the morning piece
with devastating effect
cars caught fire as the missile crashed
into the ground dozens upon dozens of
apartment windows were shattered in the
blast residents and workers immediately
started to clear up
the car park they surveyed the damaged
vehicle seeing what they could repair
I wondered if they're getting used to
all of this as you see we just try to
fix the problem and just to continue
live and hope for the best but the war
goes on right for sure all the words in
the history there
once they're all they're over so I hope
it's gonna be fast and come the peace
come soon
Council workers began delivering rolls
of plastic sheeting for people to repair
their Windows as best as possible it's
relatively mild at the moment but the
temperature here can plummet in a matter
of hours
there has been a break but these times
where the incidents have been happening
across Ukraine for months now as
civilian population had aren't getting
used to it at all they live in constant
fear that they're sort of completely in
Oculus residential area could be the
next one to get hit
Larissa took me into her apartment she
told me she thought her balcony was
going to fall off as she was shaken by
the explosion I asked her what she
thought of Russia and the war yes
China
this was a massive Russian attack on
Ukraine's energy infrastructure
a power station in Kiev burned through
the morning after a direct hit
by afternoon the fire was out but there
have been widespread power Cuts caused
by the attack
crucially and potentially
catastrophically the Zappa Richie
nuclear power plant was temporarily cut
from The Grid that's for the sixth time
listing this response from the nuclear
watchdog
are the iaea
we are meant
to care about nuclear safety
each time we are rolling a dice
and if we allow this to continue time
after time then one day our luck will
run out
Sirens periodically sounded throughout
the day
after three weeks of quiet residents
once again returned to the safety of the
metro to await the all clear
it's part of life now
working from the underground